dès à présent des demandes de prise de
parole madame Mathilde panot madame la
Présidente
merci madame la Présidente donc là vous
venez d'ailleurs de donner le titre de
la nouvelle loi que vous essayez de
faire examiner le 8 juin qui serait une
conférence de financement sur les
retraites en magouillant je le redis
pour que on ne puisse pas discuter et
voter avec les 577 députés représentants
du peuple qui ont été élus pour un bon
nombre d'entre eux et d'entre nous pour
lutter contre votre réforme des
retraites et qui dans son entièreté
veulent voter contre la retraite à 64
ans donc pour ne pas perdre le vote vous
êtes en train de transformer la loi mais
pour transformer la loi vous utilisez
quelque chose qui est inacceptable
madame la Présidente et je veux le
redire vraiment ici avec solennité il
n'est pas possible que vous vous preniez
vous pour quelqu'un qui est au-dessus de
la Constitution au dessus de ce qui est
le droit fondamental des parlementaires
c'est-à-dire le droit d'amender et vous
ouvrez un précédent déjà avec l'article
40 sur l'initiative parlementaire avec
les propositions de loi mais là avec le
refus d'examiner les sous amendements
qui est inacceptable qui est un
anticonstitutionnel je le dis parce que
ce mot a été beaucoup entendu ces
derniers temps
très bien Monsieur Pierre daredevine
extrêmement dangereux comme précédent ce
n'est pas possible je vous le dis
l'article 41 du règlement que dit-il que
la présidente ou le président de
commission effectivement pouvoir pour
organiser les travaux ça ne vous donne
pas pouvoir pour pouvoir décider de quel
amendement nous pouvons discuter ou ne
pas discuter et dans et dans cet état
des lieux vu ce que vous êtes en train
de faire qui est extrêmement grave pour
notre démocratie extrêmement grave vous
êtes des dangers pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas
continuer
de nouveau nous n'allons pas continuer
nous n'allons pas continuer à discuter
des amendements comme si rien ne s'était
passé nous n'allons pas continuer à
examiner un an les choses sans en
fermant les yeux sur l'acte
d'autoritarisme incroyable que vous avez
fait et je vais vous dire madame la
Présidente vous abaissez l'Assemblée
nationale merci bien Monsieur Pierre
Daredevil
merci madame la Présidente tout à
l'heure vous avez annoncé une décision
qui a été soumise au bureau décision que
que nous contestons n'acceptons pas
parce que nous pensons effectivement
qu'elle crée un précédent grave pour le
droit des parlementaires le droit du
Parlement et pour la démocratie tout
court donc je veux le souligner et puis
je veux également dire quel est l'enjeu
parce que ça peut paraître comme ça de
manière assez troubles aux yeux de
certains l'enjeu il est clair c'est
est-ce que l'Assemblée nationale va
pouvoir se prononcer sur la question de
l'âge légal ou pas c'est ça le sujet et
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui va décider d'être en train
de décider de savoir si la femme
nationale va se prononcer ou pas nous
nous pensons que l'Assemblée nationale
doit se prononcer c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs je pense que Charles de
Courson a déposé cette proposition de
loi donc la question qui se pose
désormais c'est bien celle là et c'est
de savoir si par-dessus le marché c'est
à dire après avoir fait tout ça après
avoir empêché l'examen des sous-amand je
le dis d'autant plus tranquillement que
moi j'en ai pas déposé et je pense que
ce droit doit être défendu pour autant
est-ce que par dessus le marché la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale va
en plus nous empêcher de déposer de
défendre un amendement de rétablissement
du taxe initial que vous avez vidé de sa
substance à l'instant c'est ça le sujet
qui se pose donc le film il est pas tout
à fait tout à fait fini mais pour ce qui
nous concerne compte tenu de la décision
que vous avez prise de nous empêcher de
véritablement discuter de porter à
nouveau atteinte au droit du Parlement
mais on va vous laisser tranquille on va
vous laisser entre vous puisque c'est
comme ça que vous êtes bien donc voilà
on veut pas déranger monsieur Arthur de
la porte
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la Présidente
ce qu'il s'est passé ce matin c'est
inédit dans l'histoire parlementaire de
la Cinquième République
sans sourciller
vous avez bafoué le droit le plus
élémentaire de notre mandat de député
vous avez ôté au Parlement le peu de
force qui lui reste
sans sourciller vous avez nié donc le
droit d'amendement des parlementaires
qui est pourtant protégé par l'article
44 de la Constitution les sous
amendements qui ont fait l'objet du
débat sont je cite indissociable du
droit d'amendement qui est sanctifié par
le Conseil constitutionnel et qui a été
reconnu ainsi depuis
1986 alors si certains collègues
préfèrent que j'évite la sanctification
je dirais simplement qui est protégé
comme la norme suprême que vous vous
êtes empressé de bafouer ce matin votre
set de pouvoir madame la Présidente et
vous l'avez dit en début de réunion pour
écarter l'examen d'un amendement chers
collègues laissez-moi finir et de
prononcer une irrecevabilité au titre de
l'article 45 ce que vous n'avez pas fait
vous n'avez pas prononcé d'y
recevabilité le droit rien que le droit
et certainement pas le fait arbitraire
d'écarter de l'examen des amendements
qui ne vous plairaient pas la présidente
de la commission n'en a pas le pouvoir
le bureau de la commission non plus
rendez-vous compte madame la Présidente
commence en sourcilier nous nous
éloignons dangereusement du chemin
démocratique sans sourciller rendez-vous
compte du précédent que vous créez en
autorisant n'importe quel président de
commission ou même de séances il y en a
deux issus du rassemblement national je
vous le rappelle de refuser d'examiner
des amendements selon leur bon vouloir
en dehors de toute règle de tout cadre
sans droit nous ne faisons pas de
politique
sans règles nous menaçons l'édifice de
nos institutions et aujourd'hui je le
dis en toute gravité parce que vous
vouliez éviter de discuter du report de
l'âge légal que vous nous avez imposé
sans vote vous voulez être assis sur la
légalité même nous ne pouvons cautionner
cela et nous partirons très bien
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
je vais associer ma voix à celle de mes
collègues pour
rappeler un tout petit peu l'historique
de ce qu'il se fait passer il y a que ce
projet de loi qui est encore une fois a
mobiliser de manière historique les
personnes une union syndicale qui n'a
jamais été aussi large et aussi solide
cette proposition ce projet de loi telle
qu'il est arrivé à l'Assemblée nationale
n'a jamais été votée par notre instance
puisqu'il y a eu des 49 3 sur quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre quand même d'un
projet de société et d'un projet de
société qui touche en premier les plus
vulnérables de notre société pour cette
raison là et parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
vote le groupe liotte qui n'est pas du
dra-goche qui n'est pas de super gauches
qui n'est pas d'extrême d'extrêmement de
gauche comme comme vous le dites sur
tous les plateaux ce groupe liotte qui
est centriste a pour
volonté de garantir
le fonctionnement démocratique et c'est
la raison pour laquelle parce qu'il a
estimé qu'en première lecture ce projet
de loi avait été bafoué et n'avait pas
été étudié comme il aurait dû l'être
pour cette raison là ils ont déposé une
nouvelle proposition de loi dans leur
niche parlementaire il se trouve que
cette nouvelle initiative est une
occasion pour vous d'aller chercher des
articles jamais usité dans le règlement
de l'Assemblée nationale et de créer un
précédent en ce qui s'est passé ce matin
à savoir que pour la première fois vous
avez franchi la ligne rouge de ce qui
n'est pas autorisé par le Règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale et en fait ce face
à quoi nous nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est constaté notre impuissance à vous
contrer dans votre volonté de toute
puissance et de ne pas vouloir perdre la
face pour cette raison là notre rôle de
parlementaire ne sert plus à grand-chose
nous le constatons et donc nous part ons
la parole est à Monsieur juin
oui madame la Présidente
à entendre un certain nombre de
remarques mais j'allais vous répondre
le droit d'amendement en réalité le
droit d'amendement madame la Présidente
il est encadré
le droit d'amendement il n'est pas
de temps puisque il y a des députés qui
ont décidé de quitter la salle voilà
voilà très bien voilà
très bien attendez monsieur le député
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît monsieur Juvin et lui seul à
la parole monsieur le député vous avez
vos deux minutes s'il vous plaît
oui madame la Présidente
l'idée que le droit d'amendement est un
droit
sans limite est une fausse idée il y a
une abondante jurisprudence
constitutionnelle
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
qui explique que le droit d'amendement
ne doit pas être détourné et le Conseil
constitutionnel plusieurs fois à jugé
que le droit d'amendement devait être
limité quand il était utilisé à des fins
autres que de faire la loi 17 mai 73
l'utilisation d'une procédure à des fins
autres que celle auquel elle doit
constitutionnellement servir est
interdite
13 janvier 94 le droit d'amendement
ouvrait les guillemets sans
justification appropriée
1994 la restriction du droit
d'amendement doit être appréciée au
regard du contenu des amendements et des
constitutions générales du débat donc
c'est une c'est un abus que de prétendre
que le droit de rendement est sacré
sanctifié tout à l'heure et ne connaît
aucune limite le droit d'amendement
peut-être apprécié eu égard à
l'utilisation réelle de ces amendements
or on avait là de l'obstruction ce n'est
que le droit constitutionnel
Aurore berger
ah ben si vous sinon il y a monsieur
Éric worth qui l'a demandé monsieur
monsieur verte vous avez la parole je
vais faire le supplétif
je regrette je regrette que nos
collègues soient partis d'abord le débat
était intéressant
et je voulais répondre je vais répondre
à ces assez brièvement au fond on a
l'impression que que les filles au
travers de tout cela a décidé de nous
donner des cours de morale du Règlement
de l'Assemblée du respect de la
Constitution son drapeau dans la
Constitution qui n'ont d'ailleurs jamais
lu et il se retrouve dans une situation
assez infernale parce que les premiers
les premiers à la bafoué quand ça les
arrange pas ils sont là par exemple
toutes leurs démonstrations reposent sur
le 49-3 ce serait pas bien d'employer le
49-3 oui enfin c'est un emploi
constitutionnel du 49-3 on peut
regretter tout ce qu'on veut on peut
avoir un débat démocratiques là dessus
enfin le fondement de la démocratie
c'est la Constitution c'est pas un texte
comme ça c'est pas un article de journal
c'est pas un programme électoral c'est
la Constitution c'est les bases
fondamentales de notre démocratie donc
toute personne qui tente de s'en
exonérer et par nature c'est loin de la
démocratie donc sur le 49-3 mais sur
l'article 40 que je connais bien je dois
être le seul ici à voir manier l'article
40 autant de temps pendant 5 ans je vois
bien que le président de la commission
des finances et les filles et j'ai grand
respect pour lui mais enfin il est et
les filles les présidents de la
commission des finances il est
normalement le gardien du temps dans
l'état d'esprit des textes de l'article
40 d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que son rôle
a été conçu autour de cela mais il a
décidé de s'exonérer totalement de
l'article 40 pour une raison partiale et
pour une raison totalement politique
alors qu'il y a pas de politique
là-dedans c'est une charge ou c'est pas
une charge ça ne se constate pas parce
que traditionnellement à l'Assemblée on
ne le constate pas au moment du dépôt
personne ne contrôle jamais le dépôt
parce que ça permet aux députés de
pouvoir déposer un certain nombre de
propositions et puis évidemment quand
les choses deviennent sérieuses et si et
si et si un député le demande il y a une
vérification de la conformité à
l'article 40 ça a été le cas il y a bien
eu une vérification de la conformité le
président de façon tout à fait
manifestement anormale a décidé que ça
n'a que ça ne n'était pas touché par
l'article 40 qui est que ce n'était pas
une charge alors que c'est par principe
une charge puisqu'il y a un gage de
charge qui est exceptionnellement
autorisé pour le dépôt il y a un gage de
charge qui est dans cette même
proposition donc on voit bien que
l'article 40 devait s'imposer et au fond
toutes ces discussions nous n'aurions
pas dû les avoir ce matin donc ceux qui
provoquent les débats sont plutôt nous
acceptons ce débat mais mais mais et les
filles ne peut pas ne peut pas ne peut
pas dire ce qu'ils disent aujourd'hui
voilà en tout cas une décision je
respecte évidemment la décision du
Bureau qui est pleine de bon sens de la
Commission
de François Gernigon
oui merci madame la Présidente je suis
assez d'accord avec Monsieur Delaporte
quand il dit que c'est passé ce matin
est assez inédit je dirais que c'est
inédit par rapport à la violence et je
regrette que mes collègues de la nuit
passe pas partie parce que en fin de
séance on a dépassé les 100 décibels je
répète je souffre de problèmes
d'audition j'ai perdu en un an ce qui me
restait sur l'oreille gauche ça m'a
déclenché à chaque fois des acouphènes
j'ai failli quitter la salle parce que
dans ces cas-là on a une tête comme un
tambour et on est pris de vertige
je réitérer ma demande auprès de la
présidente en disant que c'est
inacceptable que dans une salle comme
celle-ci ou en hémicycle on puisse
accepter ce comportement et vous devriez
avoir la possibilité les uns les autres
que ce soit les présidents
vice-président va d'exclure les
personnes qui se comportent de la sorte
parce que c'est vraiment inacceptable
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
j'espère que le cet après-midi devrait
être serein puisque
voilà la dû passer parti voilà rappelez
que il y a eu un vote donc sur l'article
de l'article 1 faut pas le faut pas
l'oublier ça c'est en marge de ce que je
voulais dire mais voilà le ce
comportement
voilà simplement c'est c'est
inacceptable
j'espère que vous trouverez une solution
que dans le réglement intérieur on
pourra inclure quelque chose peut-être
que ça existe déjà mais ce comportement
est vraiment inacceptable très bien
merci monsieur le député donc j'espère
que les débats vont pouvoir se
poursuivre de manière sereine et je
passe tout de suite la parole à Monsieur
Christophe Benz
merci madame la Présidente je suis
effectivement ravi que les choses
redeviennent un petit peu plus calmes
avec le départ mais que je regrette
finalement de la nups parce qu'ils font
partie de la représentation nationale et
j'aurais aimé dans un premier temps
répondre à Monsieur Delaporte mais il
n'est plus là je réponds quand même
puisqu'il s'inquiétait qu'il y ait deux
vices présidents RN à l'Assemblée en
l'occurrence Hélène Laporte et Sébastien
Chenu lui rappelait qu'ils ont été comme
eux élus par les Français d'abord de
leur circonscription et ensuite élu par
leur père au sein de l'hémicycle il
craignait l'arrivée au pouvoir du
rassemblement national il a évoqué le
président lors du bureau tout à l'heure
je pense que nous serons lorsque nous
arriverons pouvoir si les Français nous
font effectivement confiance dans cette
institution qui est l'Assemblée
nationale d'être les premiers à
respecter précisément la Constitution à
respecter le droit des parlementaires
leur liberté leur capacité d'initiative
et donc de déposer des amendements quoi
qu'il en coûte petite parenthèse de
passage dans les institutions et dans la
constitution et la possibilité de faire
des référendum nous avions je le
rappelle puisque nous sommes maintenant
que la nuit passée partie les seuls
opposants réel et complets à Emmanuel
Macron nous avons proposé une motion
référendaire pour donner aux Français la
possibilité de se prononcer par
référendum je rappelle que les nipples
ne l'a pas voté et donc qu'il soit
informé de cela le rassemblement
national et attaché à sa constitution et
très attachée au respect des
institutions je vous remercie
très bien alors je tiens avant de
démarrer l'examen de l'article donc 2
c'était simplement pour vous dire que
c'est pas la première fois qu'une
assemblée parlementaire donc rejette
refuse l'examen de sous amendements dès
lors que c'est sous amendements sont
déposés de manière abusive à des fins
d'obstruction nous sommes oui pour le
débat oui pour la démocratie oui pour
que les parlementaires puissent voter
NON à l'obstruction je crois que
vraiment nous partageons toutes et tous
en tous les cas ce point de vue dommage
ils sont partis effectivement les
députés de la nupesse ont quitté donc la
salle de la commission mais j'espère que
ils vont l'entendre et en plus le
Conseil constitutionnel a validé
justement ce refus du Sénat d'examiné
d'étudier donc c'est sous amendement